i have a lot of things to talk about a
lot of specifics um and i uh can't wait
to get into that but i like throwing
some curveballs at the beginning sort of
like to get to know you if you will um
and kiki i read that your parents were
both actors
uh and and i'm just curious what was
their reaction when you said to them i
want to be an actor yeah so you know i
didn't really
say that i was kind of you know always
just singing in church and i was always
interested in gay and engaged whenever
they would talk to us about how they met
and you know the kind of stuff that they
used to do working in theater and
and then one day my my dad was reading
in the newspaper about lion king
auditions like the you know just chicago
theater uh play or musical
and he just asked if i wanted to go down
he was like they have singing and they
do a little bit of acting but we like we
had mentioned to you that we did would
you ever want to do it or want to try it
out and i was like yeah and so then i
tried out you know i didn't get it but
after that then i was like
i really think i like acting i really
think i like this stuff i want to try to
keep doing more of it i think you landed
on your feet you did okay
um so look everyone watching this right
now will have not seen alice yet and i
hate doing the thing but who wants to
bite the bullet and and describe the
movie
filmmaker
that's kvl
you wrote it
um
yeah i mean i i don't want to sound
corny
but uh like give you the well
but it's it's a
it's based it's inspired by true events
uh
a woman born into slavery who
through a series of circumstances
escapes only to find that it is in fact
1973.
hopefully that wasn't robotic i don't
want to you know because i don't
get into the conversation then we'll
start to tell about the story so
totally um president you worked i
believe for tarantino for a number of
years and i am i can't i mean that must
be an amazing education so i'm curious
what did you learn
uh working for him or working with him
that you applied to your writing process
in making this film
well the writing process is like
first of all writing free hand and that
it's the most important
part of making any movie is getting
what you want down on the page including
the music
first before entering that journey
because if you don't get that right
you're not going to get the movie right
you can change in real time but it's not
going to be the same
and then on set the biggest thing that
he has always preached is
the camera operator is your best friend
wherever he goes
you go because if your actors are out in
the cold
or the elements or anything if they can
see that their their director is right
there with them weathering the storm
they're gonna give you their all
maybe kiki will disagree but
you guys
um but yeah his biggest harp was
don't be a you know don't be one of
those [ __ ] directors that's in a tent
like
10 feet away
looking on a monitor like that's not
filmmaking you know and then
i totally agree with that
yeah i do too
it's totally different when a director
is right right up in there without a
doubt
yeah
you see it in the performances you see
that connection with the with the
director and and the actor like
it's always that that emotional
connection starts early and you know
kristin got it with the
with all the actors on this for sure
i think she just wanted to be away from
me in the tent on the monitor
[Laughter]
peter what was it about this material
that pulled you in and said i want to be
involved in this
i i've been a fan of christmas writing
for
a while um and when it was presented to
me you know i i
felt like it was a story you know
they're the themes of of the script that
we had kind of seen or read before but i
think the way that she kind of treated
the material the fact that it was
inspired by true events that i had to
kind of dig into through research
kristen had given me and then this kind
of transformative journey of alice's
character the second half of the movie i
hadn't seen that before in this type of
film so i just there was a really unique
voice and then when we
started kind of talking about the script
and her desire to direct this um you
know as a first timer i mean she had
this whole movie you know played out and
set up in her head shot listed you know
the way she was going to do the
production design the music you know the
actor she wanted to work with like kiki
so it was it was kind of a no-brainer
but um the script was what kind of
looked me uh initially
uh kiki i i'm so curious
how were you presented with this script
and story did someone pull you aside and
said you just need to read the script or
did someone sort of give you a synopsis
and say then read the script because i
would imagine that information the way
it's presented to you could really
impact you
yeah i think um kristen presented it to
me in an amazing way because it was
presented through like a letter that she
wrote
to me um about how she thought that i
was uh you know the perfect person for
this role and that had never happened
before i'd never gotten anything like
that from a director or writer about
about a project
um and so that was my introduction to it
you know my representation said oh this
is a letter from kristen verlinden she's
the writing director of the script alice
and she really thinks she would be great
for the role of alice and i'm like
really she want me a letter you know
that's crazy
and you know i just thought that was
really cool and that's what prompted me
to read the script and to meet with her
and ultimately do the part
yeah i i have to do a follow-up and i'm
just curious what was your reaction once
you started getting through it and
realizing what this story was and
what the story was trying to tell
i was really happy i think even still
though you know working with her and
doing the film
it takes it even to another place than
what was actually written on there
because so much of it is visual and
and it's so much of it is like what
you're seeing
um and i was really excited to get to
know her and see how she was going to
display this movie because it was just
you know when you read it you're like oh
my gosh you know what's how is this
going to be how is that going to be
when's that going was that going to look
like who's frank you know i'm thinking
of all those things and obviously that's
a telltale that a script is good if it's
making you think all that stuff and you
know wanting you to you want to look at
it you want to see it come alive um and
so yeah i was excited because initially
you know when i did get that you know
first i realized oh it's gonna be you
know it's gonna have something to do
with slavery i was a little bit like
okay now where is it going you know what
you know how is this story gonna be told
is it gonna be i'm gonna be sad you know
what's the what's the vibe and what's
the feel so to actually get into it and
see that it was revisiting such a a
heavy complex
topic um
and part of history but still
giving us a perspective that is not
the one that we've you know kind of
accustomed to when it comes to these
kinds of themes or genres you however
you want to call it
that made me very excited because i love
to revisit the past i think there's so
much to learn in the past and i'm very
proud of my history and i thought that
this was a film that was talking about
it and telling a story about history in
a way that i want to stay tuned for you
know that doesn't make me feel dejected
or you know kind of um you know sick in
my stomach
the whole way through
uh completely um you guys sold the film
prior to it premiering at sundance and
i'm curious
what was did you guys behind the scenes
debate you know like
holding the film back to premiere at
sundance and see what would happen and
were you sort of like you know can you
sort of take me through that kind of
discussion because i've spoken to a
number of filmmakers and there's that
debate of what do we want to do
with the film
well from from my perspective you know
before producing i spent a lot of time
on the distribution side of things and
you know because the landscape has
changed so much even in the last you
know uh
year from when we finished the movie uh
the distribution landscape has changed
so you know the idea of trying to um
kind of wait for you know festival
acceptance you know knowing whether the
festivals are happening or not um
it's uh it's a tricky proposition so i
think it was it was more timing of when
we had finished the film
we didn't have the sundance information
at the time um and so it was you know we
felt like timing uh to kind of screen
for distributors was was right you know
whether we made the correct choice or
not you know who knows these days it's
always uh hindsight 2020 but i think the
days of uh these these movies selling at
festivals in the kind of frenzy
marketplace that it used to be i just
you know unless things come back to
being in person where you have you can
create that uh
that kind of marketplace uh frenzy
um you know the distributors have have
the time and and can you know be a bit
more sensible uh unfortunately with
their decisions and and their checkbooks
um but you know i think we're very happy
with the the home we found and um you
know we're getting a theatrical release
which i think the movie deserves i mean
i know kristen and myself and kiki
wanted to make a movie that deserves to
be up on the big screen and it looks
beautiful and i still believe in
you know that
that enjoyment of of of cinema but you
know the realities are like you know
there's so many different platforms of
ways to see
you know movies these days you have to
you have to start embracing it and you
know it's going to be a kind of a mix
but yeah look it's it's uh it's a
difficult
uh choice to make it's you know
sometimes financial sometimes it's
creative um but you know i think it's
hard just to hold on and kind of oh what
about sundance oh what about this um
you know you just don't know
yeah and by the way i've spoken to so
many people there is no right answer
because i've i've also spoken to people
who have made really good movies and
they're totally expecting to sell at the
festival and then it's sort of quiet and
then you know like i i think just
congratulations on selling your movie
and getting it out
that's the most important thing i was
just curious how it go how you guys
discussed it you know um kristen so the
movie's called alice obviously how many
other alt titles did you have or is it
always alice uh the first title was 55
acres and then peter i think it was you
or someone told me
oh that sounds like spike lee's
production company
so so i changed the name and then i i
was
thinking of what should i call it and i
was like duh call it alice
because it's about alice and she
she is she's the entire story
um kiki you have
a number of very powerful moments in the
film and i'm just curious
you have a i was gonna curse a very
large scene
on like a monday and um and you know
you're going to have to emotionally
deliver how early on are you preparing
for that moment in your head with the
dialogue and how you want to play
how it is for me
it's living and building up for me
before i even set foot on stage and i
don't know how healthy that is but
that that's how i've been doing it since
i was a kid that it literally starts to
live in me and the concept and the
feelings and the emotions of the
character start to become a part of my
everyday life from the moment that i say
i'm doing this role it literally you
know i could be eating food or something
like how would alice eat food it would
just come to me you know what i mean
just because i know i'm doing the role
and at that point everything
every human response that i have
interaction
any response that someone has to me
immediately becomes um immediately
becomes material
completely i i i've heard this from
other it's so interesting hearing
talking to actors and hearing the
different ways people work um kristin i
am curious
you mentioned this is inspired by true
events can you sort of talk about what
was it that you read or watched that all
of a sudden you know sparked you in a
frenzy to write this
yeah it was uh coming from the place of
being a screenwriter for 10 years and my
mom
constantly trying to pitch me her ideas
or send me articles that will lead to
stories so she could say see it you know
see i told you i gave you that uh and
she usually they're not good but she
gave me
a bunch of the a
bunch of links and a bunch of scan
papers from her uh friend who's a
professor at berkeley
and i she kept bugging me about it over
the weekend so i read it right away read
all of them
and there were multi there all of the
stories are inspiring but the specific
one that
drove that stayed in my heart and soul
was this woman
who um the journalist wrote it really
cool because she doesn't tell us
anything she just
describes what's going on that she's
walking with this woman and she's
talking a woman saying how do you feel
coming back here and the woman starts to
say well you know i feel this or that
and then she starts saying you know well
now that we're getting closer to the
plantation and as a reader you're going
like wait what like what is she talking
about
and um then as they get there she tells
her story and it was so
moving and and
inspiring for so many different reasons
for
the reason that she didn't lose her
spirit
being
born into slavery like literal slavery
it wasn't like share
sharecroppers and we owe money it was
literally she was born into slavery not
knowing anything
and the only education she could have
was through the stories that her her
mother or father or any of the relatives
had
and um it was not only
how she
handled herself growing up that way but
when she
did run away
how she
empowered herself and what she did with
her life and the the biggest difference
between
all of those stories and alice is
the
all of them took place in the 60s and i
wanted alice to emerge into the 70s when
there's been a little bit of time to
reflect on the civil rights movement and
have a character like frank that was a
part of that movement and has lost
hope because he's like man it didn't go
anywhere and for her to be that spark
for him
and um so yeah that was the the
biggest thing was the 70s but everything
else
sadly the the stories that i read were
were
so so um
violent
uh that i i wouldn't put that in the
movie but
yeah
for all three of you um i love learning
about like the random behind-the-scenes
stories fun stuff about the making of
the film even though this is a very
powerful movie um so for all three of
you what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the actual making
of the film
you know maybe i mean i don't know if
they would be surprised by this but we
really were having a good time with one
another i mean yes there was some heavy
stuff and those scenes were difficult
but
i have nothing but fond memories of
shooting atlas you know uh you know i
really loved working with christian i
loved working with peter i loved being
in savannah i loved working with common
um all of us couldn't wait to get to the
70s portion of the movie needless to say
but you know it was a it was an
enjoyable time it was we were bonding
and you know it all was happening
interestingly enough around the around
the election as well
um so it was just a lot of energy and
it was it was a it was a wonderful time
filming that movie
and cove had brought us closer because
we all were in alignment of if one of us
messes up
you know the whole ship goes down and by
messes up if one of us tests positive
like let's be really careful about what
we do when we're not filming or you know
what we're doing on set like
i never saw anybody without their mask
on except for the actors and that was
just the norm and we got we got through
it because everybody it takes a village
everybody had to be
in alignment with each other
yeah like uh any any independent film
and a good day is uh is difficult and
you know we had uh early days of covid
you know we were going to start shooting
in the summer
uh you know the lovely state of georgia
weren't going to stop us continuing but
you know the health department made the
advice of you know pack your [ __ ] and
get the [ __ ] out of here um so we had to
kind of pause and and came back in the
fall but like kristen said like everyone
was in it together everyone was there
for the right reasons um and then the uh
the addition of
uh the election happening you know
shooting in in in southern georgia you
know where there are rallies going on uh
next door to where we're shooting on a
plantation just added that extra um
you know a bit of energy and and kind of
purpose to what we were trying to do and
and i think you know hopefully
the audience at the end of the day can
kind of see that in in in what we made
um but no it look it's uh it was hard
you know
every time i would get the email from
the uh the cobit supervisor with the
test results is
please please please
uh but we did it and it was you know
because everyone was very diligent and
and took it seriously and
and uh you know i
not looking forward to doing that again
um kristen i'm i'm curious you obviously
there's different structures the film
has different structures you have the
stuff on the plantation then you have
alice um i'm this is not spoiler you
know uh you know alice in the in the 70s
so i'm just curious can you sort of talk
about how you figured out how much time
do i want to spend on the plantation
showing this life how much time do i
want to spend here how much time do i
want to spend there um can you sort of
talk about how you put that together
well i think
it's it's
a few things uh the first one is just as
a screenwriter this is going to sound
corny but you know like okay by 30
minutes in
you know you have to you have the
structure as as a writer of like pace
and and
how much a reader wants to be in a
certain world before they get out so
there's that aspect but then um there's
also a big inspiration
for
the film as far as um even desaturation
was the movie stalker
uh andre tarkovsky's movie so i used
that as a big reference as far as
going from one world into another
and how long that takes and and how we
get to know him and what he's going
through before
we're submerged into
this colorful
totally different world than he came
from
uh pam greer is obviously not in the
film but she is in the film um and i'm
just curious if you guys can sort of
talk about what pam greer means to you
and uh why uh kristen why you decided
coffee would be the film
that uh alice goes to see
hamburger was my hero growing up there
weren't too many heroes other than my
mom
and my grandma and oprah
so you know like you also have a
personal connection to pam you got to
talk about yeah my uncle dated her in
the 70s
he was a boxer
he was a boxer but he was a black
exploitation actor so he played mandingo
in the movie mandingo
and he was in drum
but um wow
kristen
you didn't know that
no
uh but so pam graham was just my hero in
general and i remember the first time i
saw coffee
and what that did for me going to school
like that changed even my whole outlook
in middle school of like how i carried
myself because i was the only
person of color in my middle school so
it was like
i i came with a different swagger and
she just meant so much to me
so of course
when you're when you have a character
like alice it's like man who will really
like give her an injection of like no
this is like i'm gonna take matters into
my own hands like of course pampers that
person and of course coffee is that
movie i i know we have to wrap up but do
you have any sort of personal connection
to pam what does she mean to you
um in in regards to
her representation and how the community
feels about her my mom has always you
know so crazy but my mom always said
you're like pam greer she would always
mention pam greer in my life you know
about representation and how she feels
about me and my power and how i can own
my power as an entertainer as a talent
you know my mom has always said you know
you know um encouraging things like that
to me um but i think i really did my
real research on the artwork uh of pam
grier with kristen you know coming into
alice that was a big part of
the movie for her and for me to really
dive into so it went from hearing how
people feel about pam grier
understanding what she means and kind of
just feeling like i know her because of
that and then doing my own personal
research i just think she was such a
strong you know black woman at the time
it was you know i think very very
outspoken in a in a great way in already
a tough industry and i think you know
she almost had kind of this superhero uh
nature about her which i think you know
kiki and alice kind of uh embodies in
that kind of you know second half of the
movie
in life
that answer change i would say kiki
palmer is my hero
and i'm not just saying that like it's
she's all our hero
on that note i really want to say a
sincere congratulation uh
congratulations on this film uh i know
people are going to enjoy this one and
uh congrats on being part of the
sundance film festival and i really
appreciate you guys talking to me about
the movie i wish you all nothing but the
best and good luck with the rest of your
speed dating
you